in polish policy towards Ukrainian
minority at the same time while
analyzing called Landers or twists of
this policy pero makes this final
question very important could we name as
some Ukrainian I don't call them
historians but propagandist say could we
call polish policy towards Ukrainian
during the interwar period totalitarian
or could we call both great entire
Ukrainian actions from 1931 and sort of
from 1930 and 1938-39 ethnic cleansing
with 20 or maybe a little bit less
casualties I specifically mentioned this
Ukrainian position taken by some
extremist Ukrainian so to speak
historians in order to urge our
Ukrainian colleagues to compare once
again the situation of Ukrainians in
Poland however cruel it was to situation
of Ukrainians in the Soviet Ukraine
after 1931 but it seems to me that much
more important from polish
historiography point of view is to
compare the situation as regards polish
politics to a Ukrainian minority to
Russian Imperial policy towards poles
during the second half of 19th century
it seems to me that this is the most
promising
promising sphere of comparisons between
two national politics or state politics
towards the most important the most
destructive national from the state
point of view problem so comparative
point of view and new comparisons not
only regarding general policy but also
comparison between some some both polish
and Ukrainian social groups some cities
between polish side and Soviet side of
Ukrainian life like beef and for example
hockey this are I think the most
promising the most prospective sides of
historiography that will be taken I'm
sure in the nearby future by polish
historiography thank you know before
what is lot like this one what is love
the best soup and I would like to ask
the question first polysilicon
what is a passionate person what the
smell the focus of the studious lecture
is in Ukrainian and I wonder if we
understand everybody understand
Ukrainian because I way to
colima was acquitted proclaims kapoor
schistosome catch a super-sensitive in
NATO he is a keen chinita dressage is
permitted when a kya were a knavish ask
oh ho that was draw a quick net what's a
tow-rope it appears in his nail spindly
poquito cream skype or scare me Nikhil
yay kilka payasa in turquoise selective
nagy permittee the sample at says the
richness national varshavsky who are
they okay we should the Lakers imagine
claims football skills too soon kill
Ebola practitioners thi nhu much tab
news prob'ly Oh liquid I see Bill
Schuette kurashima immense wrestler and
below a test sure the sss avedon ski bit
with this is joseph is in the citrate
yokatta petoskey t situation so
deviatoric oh pallakki ukraine's of
persia brother which is tyranny millet
army RC noisy channel a national courts
us to drill